- God save the King!
- [All] God save the King!
(trumpets blaring)
(upbeat band music)
(crowd cheering)
- Very nice pageantry.
- It's great.
And when the carriage went past, wow.
(bells ringing)
(mellow music)
(trumpets blaring)
(organ music)
(soft music)
(indistinct chatter)
(trumpets blaring)
(bright music)
- I come not to be served, but to serve.
(lighthearted music)
(men singing in foreign language)
- Receive this orb, receive
this ring, receive this glove
that you may hold authority
with gentleness and grace.
(organ music)
♪ God save our gracious king ♪
♪ Long live our noble king ♪
♪ God save the king ♪
(canyons blasting)
(officers shouting)
(canyon blasting)
(bells ringing)
(upbeat band music)
(lively band music)
(crowd cheering)
- [Protesters] Not my king!
Not my king!
- His Majesty's Armed Forces royal salute!
Present arms!
(armed forces marching)
Hip hip!
- [Armed Forces] Hooray!
(crowd cheering)
(planes whooshing)